so you guys may have seen this early
yesterday morning there was a stabbing
in Brooklyn New York at a baaad house
and it's actually not getting a lot of
mainstream coverage okay so just to be
clear what you're seeing there is after
the stabbing so 22 year-old Levi
Rosenblatt was stabbed by Calvin Peters
49 Calvin obviously is the one who got
shot he is dead he did die later in the
hospital
Mayor Bill DeBlasio New York City Mayor
basically said the cops did the right
thing so I'd want to get into the my new
shove all this stuff but first I just
want to start with are you guys just
totally sick of seeing these things we
are in a rash of just seeing everything
all the time and now we're seeing plenty
of fallout from all these videos too but
how desensitized are you becoming to
these kind of videos I mean I feel like
a lot of people are becoming
desensitized because you keep saying it
everywhere and I feel like in this
particular case the cop did the right
thing because he was coming at him with
a knife and he had just stabbed someone
yeah but there's a lot of backlash right
now with cops after dealing with all the
Ferguson stuff and all the stuff dealing
with that so people are really angry
with cops and I read a lot of the
comments through this article and we're
like why didn't the cop use martial arts
to try to
Pam and I'm like he was running at you
with a knife that he just used to stab
someone in the head yeah so so that part
I also think is interst of how
desensitized are you feeling about this
stuff in general
well I generally don't watch them I this
is the first time I saw it you sent the
article ahead of time but I didn't
actually watch the video and I think
some people feel that way some people do
maybe enjoy watching this but I'm glad
it's happening I've got to be honest I'm
glad that people are taking out their
cell phones and taking video because
even though we've seen unfortunately
recently that those videos don't
necessarily always change the outcome of
a grand jury trial yeah at least we know
that there is evidence in place at least
we know that in certain situations where
there could be excessive use of force
where things that used to happen kind of
behind closed doors are now out in the
light individuals can kind of be a part
of that of that justice process yeah do
you guys think it's important to
sometimes see the ones of these where
the cops do do the right thing also
because at first if I don't understand
why they don't have tasers in a
situation like that like it seems to me
if you're five feet away from the guy or
at least shoot his leg but I'm not going
to judge what they do because I'm not a
cop in this case yes he had a knife and
he could any just stab someone so there
certainly was imminent threat but do you
think the reason that some video like
this doesn't get picked up is it doesn't
quite fit the narrative that we have
going now and in general the media is
good with one narrative for a while and
they really like something that just
reinforces the narrative no matter what
it is yeah I agree with that actually a
couple of my friends the other day on
Facebook we're posting videos of people
attacking cops for no reason just
walking up to cops and you know calling
them names and throwing chairs at them
and he posted it with the caption saying
you know this happened too because I
feel like only one side of the story is
being shown a lot of the time so this
story maybe didn't hit as well with the
media because it wasn't villainizing
cops gosh that's terrible yeah that's
awful
I you know I have a different take and
maybe my take is a little more boring or
cata sensational but I see this is a
local news story you know it's New York
City
just like in Los Angeles there are
recently a guy was wielding a knife on
Hollywood Boulevard he got shot by
police it was an open-and-shut case
local violence unless you see usually
unfortunately a mass shooting or unless
you see something with like kind of ex
in circumstances like excessive use of
force it usually doesn't get national
attention it would be really depressing
if the national news was constantly
covering of course local stories and I
think this is just a kind of an
open-and-shut case I mean we all see the
evidence it was the cops are doing their
job yeah and I totally hear you on that
and that's why the local I never watch
the local news because the note as
depressing as the national news is the
local news is endless and it's kind of
stuff I thought this one just in light
of the narrative we have going on now
and there's a hate crime element to it I
just thought it would have been picked
up more so I was a little bit surprised
but what do you guys think about the
Taser thing like why is that like I know
everyone's big on cops should have
cameras now that's like the new thing
but what about the table I don't more
cops have didn't used to have those
things that were like antennas wait you
could actually wear you know it somehow
they were very low and you could like
hit somebody in their legs to knock them
down or not the knife out of there I
don't know that they all had and I'm
sure it depends on precincts and all
that kind stuff but what why is that not
even being discussed or rubber bullets
just something some like non-lethal
force because it's true that guy had a
knife he didn't have a gun there
probably would have been away if they
had the appropriate tools to subdue him
I mean who knows I think they were doing
their jobs the best of their ability but
if they had better tools they may have
been able to prevent you know this crime
or or you know yeah I actually heard
that too about the Los Angeles guy with
a knife and they were saying why didn't
they try to use like some sort of
martial arts on him or a Taser or
something like that and I understand
that to a degree but you also don't know
what other weapons that person might
have on them Yeah right have a gun I
mean martial arts will be ridiculous I'm
not sure all are cut through ninjas be
exactly like hand-to-hand combat is
different than shooting somebody with a
beanbag or a rubber bullet or something
that might stun them drop them to their
knees so that you could rush in and cuff
them right let's action or that's where
this this discussion should be going
about alternate ways to stop bad things
I also think a discussion and I hate to
extend the conversation but a discussion
about whether or not hate crime
legislation is something that should
exist is a whole other conversation
because I think their First Amendment
rights that that that brings up I used
to as a younger person not that I'm any
less liberal now I just think I'm more
of a cold
now let's think I'm getting older and
more more kind of deferential of a
constitution I I worry a little bit
about hate crime legislation because I
worry about being the thought police
yeah well I definitely I struggle with
that too because yes clearly in this
case they're not saying it's a hate
crime by the way conversation stable
right but it seems like if you walk into
a place where you know there's going to
be Orthodox Jews or Muslims like you
know things like all kill all video yeah
seems a little hate crime II as opposed
to walking into a drugstore and you know
shooting the guy that stocking the the
shell but there are always is that worse
I had always limits I mean isn't any man
who is who does you know domestic
battery and abuse targeting women you
know at at a certain point where do you
draw the line I also had bipolar
disorder exactly so so what they're
mentally unstable
do the heck does the hate crime
legislation really make as much sense I
bet you could probably argue or find out
I bet you there would be empirical proof
that most of these people are you know
have some sort of mental disorder so
most people don't kill for fun yeah
usually there's some sort of driving
force in it and a lot of times it has to
do with mental health
[Music]